Joe there was some tricks you guys were
shooting in some very cold weather and
will was very helpful with that was he
not I mean there was they have rain
towers that they like took from the
groundwater in Toronto it was like icy
cold so we were all just like we were
miserable in that and then we'll had the
brilliant idea of getting in like a
bucket of like steaming hot water and
he'd get this little bucket and he's
like sneak up to people that were like
standing his shivering to death and then
you'd like pour it down there next and
you could just like seeing people
standing there then they were like it
was like it was sensual and he was going
around he was running around like a
little kid in the candy store he was
like and then it like caught on so
everybody was taking these little
buckets and like pouring on each other
so every it was turned like a little
weird in there the whole crew was like
looking at us give me job get me
Oh
Oh Joe thank you
and then the sound guys they were they
were not so happy like we were pouring
water into their microphone so we were
like y'all are like killing us here so
it was very warm but you guys won't hear
any of the dies a lot of crackling and
shorting out to most of them
[Music]